[Music]
in uganda people have been waiting since
dawn for this their first dose of the
kova 19 vaccine but here the shots are
in short supply
activists say that's due in part to the
demands of pharmaceutical companies
western countries have to seek
permission before they donate unused
vaccines to poorer nations
vaccine producers say to assure the
shots remain safe but time is of the
essence
if you leave pockets of unvaccinated
people in sub-saharan africa
there are chances that
new variants could emerge from here
that might threaten
the health of people the people in the
developed world
it's a race against time and competing
interests in the fight against covet 19.
this is your kovit 19 special on dw i'm
janel dumalaon
industrialized nations have already
donated tens of millions of vaccine
doses via the uens covax vaccine program
but it's a slow process meanwhile many
countries are hoarding millions of doses
that will expire soon saying they're not
easily able to pass them on to poorer
nations by one u.n estimate almost half
a million donated vaccine doses expired
before they could be used in africa
where less than three percent of the
population has had their first shot
the first delivery of donated
coronavirus vaccines from the united
states arrives in nairobi promising a
shot in the arm for kenya's troubled
vaccination program
like many african countries kenya's
vaccination program has been plagued by
a shortage in the global supply of
vaccine doses
less than two percent of kenyans are
fully inoculated against covid19
across the nation over four and a half
thousand people have officially died of
covert 19 but this figure is believed to
be an underestimate
hospital beds are filling up with
covid19 patients as the delta variant of
the coronavirus spreads
and more people are following official
health advice and getting the jab
members of the maasai community queued
at this health facility south of kenya's
capital nairobi
i've been hearing on the radio that
there's this vaccination drive going on
and i decided to also come and get
vaccinated
i will tell people especially my
generation this disease adversely
affects us old people i'll tell them to
come to the health center and get
vaccinated
if richer countries donate more vaccine
doses faster
kenya's older generation might avoid the
worst of the pandemic
for more i'm joined by alberto jubillini
he's a senior research fellow at the
oxford uh center for practical ethics
thanks for joining us now you're an
ethicist do you see a problem in the
slow transfer of unused vaccines from
rich countries to poor countries
uh yes so there is a problem of course
there are many problems actually one
problem is that
there are vaccines that are going to
expire and we are not going to use in
the rich countries and this looks like a
big waste of resources especially given
how much these other countries need
these vaccines so there is a problem
with vaccines that
are
wasted and there is a problem with
vaccines that are not going to be wasted
but we should many countries like in the
uk european countries are going to use
for the booster those for the third dose
so we're go there is nation where some
countries some people in certain
countries the most vulnerable people
will have three dozen of the vaccines
and certain people who equally the
vaccine in poor country will not have
any dose of the vaccine so there are two
different kinds of problems but the
outcome is the same there is a big
inequity in the way we are distributing
vaccines
are you saying then that booster shots
especially at this time are unethical
no i'm not saying that uh so the booster
shots is an indicator there is some big
inequality but not only inequalities are
unethical so countries have a special
responsibility towards their own
citizens that's true for any resource
not just a vaccine and if it turns out
that vulnerable people in in rich
countries need the booster dose because
otherwise their immunity would wane i
think it is the state's responsibility
to make sure that they get the vaccine
because countries governments have
special responsibilities toward their
own citizens the problem is not so much
with the booster those problems that
rich countries are now
vaccinating very young people including
children in some countries children and
young people are at a very very low risk
of from covenanting so i think that the
ethical problem if anyone is here is
when we want to target people who are
very very low risk
of getting covered in a situation where
all the vulnerable people are vaccinated
anyway and we are not caring enough
about poor countries so i think if
anything is that those that would go to
young people that need to be given needs
to be given to
poor countries not so much the third
booster those for vulnerable people in
rich
countries now looking at
pharma companies do you have the sense
that they are doing what they can to get
the world vaccinated
um well you can always do more than what
you're doing of course because
inequality exists and we have the
resources uh there is a question whether
the main responsibilities on companies
and governments on both uh because for
example
astrazeneca is selling its vaccines at
cost so astrazeneca is not making any
profits from the vaccine until the
pandemic lasts and astrazeneca in some
countries including the netherlands is
encouraging local authorities and the
government to give the vaccines that are
going to expire that they cannot use to
poor countries so uh i don't know
exactly it is about all the countries
every company has with every country but
i will not a priority blame only the
companies because there are exceptions
to what might be perceived as the
combination of these big companies i
think government should take the
responsibility for the policies towards
their own citizens but also toward
poor countries
so are you saying that western countries
in fact do have a moral obligation to
consider the health care systems in
other countries and not just their own
yeah it's a difficult balance strike
between internal interest and global
interest and interest of the most
vulnerable and most vulnerable countries
but they certainly do have a
responsibility to do that and the
question is how to strike this balance
between internal needs and global needs
and what has suggested that if anything
that the vaccine that should be should
be given to poor countries or those that
are destined to children not to the old
people but yeah they certainly have a
responsibility and that's true in the
same way as they have responsibilities
with regard to any other scarce
resources for example each country
that's in each rich country that's in a
part of their
uh
revenue from taxes to foreign aid for
example every year and we should see
vaccines in the same way as a way that
each country have to assist poor
countries and a responsibility they have
to help poor countries
alberto giubilini a senior research
fellow at the oxford duahiro center for
practical ethics thank you so much
time now for one of your questions over
to our science correspondent derek
williams
[Music]
is it better for countries to vaccinate
with a range of vaccines instead of only
using one type
this is another of those questions that
science won't be able to answer while
we're still kind of in midstream with
the pandemic we'll have to wait i think
until we've
crossed over to the other side and can
look back at it to come up with
assessments on on really big questions
about what we got right and what we got
wrong but but that said there there's
certainly one big thing
to bear in mind when looking at this
issue which is
that we're trying to vaccinate billions
of people all over the planet as quickly
as possible now i've said the word
unprecedented many many times on this
show and i have to say it again here
this vaccination drive is unprecedented
we're in totally
new territory and it's clear
that in this race we have to use every
tool at our disposal
and safe and effective vaccines aren't
the most powerful tool that we have so
if exhaustive trials prove that a
vaccine is safe and that it's effective
then the most important thing is to get
it into as many arms as possible as
quickly as possible regardless of
manufacturer or platform for most
countries for for obvious reasons
that's going to mean using a range of
vaccines from a range of manufacturers
in this situation
trying to decide if it's better for
countries to vaccinate with a variety of
vaccines instead of one perfect one
is like asking which vaccine is best you
can't answer that
certainly not now and if you tried you'd
likely be seeing something else next
week or next month as the pandemic
evolves and as we learn more but
i will say
that to me at least
the old proverb about
not putting all of your eggs in one
basket makes sense here as well
after all betting on a range of products
spreads the risk if some vaccines don't
prove as effective against variance or
or as long lasting as we'd hoped
[Music]
you